put on the suit let's go a few rounds
who do you think is stronger Captain
America or Iron Man oh well I'm biased
um so I'm going to say cap but who's
smarter who's richer uh I'll I'll give
those to Tony
[Music]
Fantastic Four
now picture that
but everywhere I wasn't a big comic book
reader I read a lot now but but at the
time and aside from like the 80s and
early 90s Batman Superman things like
that that new wave of superhero films
the Spider-Man the X-Men they had just
begun so it was really exciting you know
marvel hadn't even kind of taken back
their name yet so it was that film was
at Fox it was one of the bigger movies I
had done up until that point so I was
ecstatic and it was a fun role to play
it was full of life and he reacted the
way I probably would have reacted if I
was given superpowers
I'm so close to Flying guys I can taste
it you can't fly yet Johnny can you put
you put that happen out
oh Jesus well it was the first time
doing those big action-y stunts you know
you show up on a set that's two blocks
long and these giant cables and
explosions and green screens and it's
you know the stuff you see in the making
ofs on other films you know and it's
kind of like wow I I make movies this is
great and just having a good time with
the cast we had a lot of fun this was in
the early 2000s this is before social
media I think everyone probably had a
Nokia flip phone you know so it still
was a time where you know in between
takes everyone's not buried in their
phone you're conversing and you know at
night you're socializing yeah it's my
early 20s it was a good time
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
Marvel had big plans that the goal was
to create this tapestry and integrate
these worlds in a way that really hadn't
been done prior and I knew what the
comic books offered me you know just
about the character with like most
Comics there's a number of different
writers who are writing for that
character and a number of different
story lines so you're not quite sure
which one they're going to follow yeah
it wasn't a whole lot about where the
character was going to end up it was
more about you know the burden of trying
to create this universe but that didn't
really fall in my lap that was other
people's responsibility and we had Downy
driving the you know what I mean
like he had already done so well with
Iron Man and it was such a phenomenon
that you you kind of felt like okay this
is
we're off on the right foot before we
get started
does anyone want to get out
you want to see how the fans see him you
know what I mean anytime I've heard
about movies that are being made or
remade something that's dear to me you
realize how protective and possessive
you are over that role and you want to
make sure the person playing the
character respects that perspective and
isn't just like well you know I know
they know the character but this is my
time and I'm gonna do my thing that's
stumbling right out of the gate so first
step try to understand why other people
like them and honor it as best you can
Avengers
[Music]
assemble there's a lot of fun moments in
end game because it's a lot of moments
that are servicing the fandom but for a
lot of those prep Montage where we're
about to go back and get the Stones it's
kind of some of the original people and
we just got to be in this room for weeks
I obviously really like the scene where
I pick up Milner for the first time
[Music]
[Applause]
in game
it's just you're fully aware of what you
got to be a part of you're really just
kind of uh so grateful every day and
just trying to
absorb it all you know I think when
you're in the middle of it it's just
always like as another Marvel movie next
year not that you take it for granted
but it just doesn't resonate the same
way when you know wow we're rapping in a
couple weeks and I'm putting the shield
down and that's just it's been such a
big part of my life for a decade so most
of end game was
a really really lovely experience how
does it feel
someone else's
it isn't that last day was you know
emotional it's like graduating school I
mean like you know today's coming and
then it's all of a sudden here and you
feel like it went by way too quick and I
mean it's life-changing my life is
forever not the same my family's life
isn't I mean I mean like the ripple
effect of signing up for that role is
kind of immeasurable for me at least and
it was a beautiful time full of
gratitude
Scott Pilgrim versus the world
you really don't know about the league
um the seven evil X's coming to kill you
controlling the future of Ramona's love
life
no Oh Hey listen man don't worry about
it really yeah
the pitch for Scott Pilgrim was so
strange but he kind of said you know
Lucas Lee is this movie star but he
really doesn't have much range and he
thinks he's great but he's actually
terrible and I think you'd be perfect I
said okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
he spent a lot a lot of time trying to
get me to look comfortable but at the
end of the day I'm still hanging off the
cables and had a rig where my shoe was
connected to the skateboard so when I
try an ollie it comes up with me so I
mean you know but you dive in because
you're in this big warehouse and Mary's
in the corner working with swords and
Mike and Jason are over there doing this
big action sequence so you know you're
just happy to be a part of it that's
probably the most fun I've had on a
movie again early in my career 20s but a
big cast of people in the same place I
want to have his adopted babies the cast
was very connected
hey
hey I'm not stupid oh
double
he's good right leaving was
heartbreaking it truly was like the
first time I was like I mean I can just
hang out guys if you need me to you know
it's you don't want to miss a beat
another film where there was a rehearsal
period that was more physical based you
know a lot of people had action
sequences I had to learn how to
skateboard but the rehearsal was so fun
then you leave and come back a month
later to do your bit and you just have
such horrible fomo you just you know
what you guys been doing have you ever
been having fun send me pictures yeah to
this day that email chain is still very
active when I first saw it after they
finished the edit before it had been
released I saw it and was just like
this movie is gonna be huge you know and
then oddly it kind of came and went the
moons that have to align for a movie to
not just be good but find success is is
a lot but it's nice to know that that
one continues to find new audiences and
it's kind of created a little bit of
like a cult following that's why we're
doing this animated series and I've just
never been a part of something where all
Edgar had to do was say hey you guys
want to do this and it was a race to
jump in everyone yes of course of course
no no brain room so yeah it's it's a
little family
mind another team movie
at that point I would have taken any
movie but yeah to be able to Spook some
of those films that I grew up on was a
treat
[Music]
hi Jake
there was Ferris Bueller elements my dad
in the movie was was ferris's dad you
know just to be in any way somewhat
adjacent to Ferris Bueller was pretty
exciting at the time
is more intimidating keeping things
fresh on a film set is the biggest
challenge drama you can always find
something to make it feel honest comedy
you know when you tell a joke or you
know you you know the comedic Rhythm
that's coming it's very easy to get
stale you got to be really Nimble and
just intrinsically funny which I don't
know that I am so it's it's an uphill
battle
Knives Out
stop stop stop stop stop
you drives down
Ransom call me Ransom it's my middle
name I mean I love a murder mystery I
love an ensemble I love the majority I
mean that cast is just phenomenal and
Ryan Johnson again another director who
really knows what he wants and it was a
role that I felt confident in it was an
intimidating role just because a lot of
the characters are colorful
um and you don't quite know how far to
go and how grounded do I make this and
again you let Ryan guide you but it was
just a dream job is that a blast with a
good law
have I'll be out in no time and then
you'll see just how much hell I can
wreak on your life you vicious little
oh that was a great scene I didn't love
getting the puke in my face
[Music]
what
I have such a love for Michael Shannon I
just think he's the funniest guy I don't
think anyone realizes how he's so dry
and so sharp and he knows he's funny too
he'll make these like you know kind of
quiet side comments and just have the
littlest mark on his face
so that we were doing that scene where
he's shoving the cookies in my face and
just screaming how about some more
cookies
a whole glass of milk and as well
took all the meats and not break
he's just he's very committed absolutely
hilarious so that that might be my
favorite scene
snow peers
[Music]
[Applause]
when I first read the script I didn't
quite get it I was like so what's you
know whenever it's a world a movie
that's uh World building you know you're
creating a completely separate
environment there's just kind of a
conceit that you have to say Okay so
everyone just accepts this this is just
how it is no one's kind of outraged that
this is the structure that's just the
normal kind you kind of have to decide
what part of your brain do you spend
time wrapping your head around you go
the intimate Road and just kind of make
it about the character do you try and
make it about what it took for that
Society to level into that place it's a
challenge but you get to watch till the
swinton's in the movie you get to watch
her approach to this Larger than Life
character precisely 74 of you shall die
foreign
you suffer from the misplaced optimism
of the doomed again we had some good
rehearsal on that project as well and
director bong is such a Visionary when
when you're working with someone that
knows exactly what they want even if
it's not exactly the way you saw it it
breeds trust and and that that as an
actor that's the most important thing to
trust the director otherwise you're
playing defense otherwise you're like
this first take I'll do this just so I
can at least protect that then I'll try
this but I don't want to try that
because I don't know if they know how to
use that take and any take I give them
could be used against me and you know
when you have a director who is so
convinced of what their vision is that's
when you say great when you say John
Paul say how high
[Music]
we had those cars on gimbals these
little like you know they just do like a
subtle movement so a lot of boat legs at
the end of the day you kind of are
wobbly getting back to your hotel room
incredibly uh
helpful the tangible environment as
opposed to Marvel where you're talking
to green screens and imaginary aliens
everything was you know right there for
you to touch and react with
sunshine
do I have to spell it out for you
we have a payload to deliver to the
heart of our nearest star we're
delivering that payload because that
star is dying and if it dies we die
everything dies so that is our mission
there is nothing literally nothing more
important than completing our mission
he's very ossified in a lot of ways but
he's kind of the engine he's kind of the
moral compass he prioritizes the mission
first at the cost of people's feelings
in a lot of ways he's very clean he
believes strongly in what he believes in
for the most part selfless you know and
and there's a mission and he's going to
get it done and I like that I like those
kind of roles
we do not have enough oxygen reserves to
get us to our payload delivery point
let alone to survive the return Journey
so cancel the ticker tape parade
I was well aware of Danny Boyle I mean
he's a major Talent he really comes from
the theater world too so to that end the
approach was very rehearsal based you
know in my short career at that point I
certainly had never had
a film that had that much prep time the
whole cast got out there a couple weeks
before Danny had us all lived together
in these little apartments for a couple
weeks experienced loss of space we did
scuba lessons to experience
weightlessness he would rent out
theaters to watch these you know Das
Boot and all the right stuff just all
these movies to put us in the right
mindset we did tons of rehearsing and it
got to a point that by the time you were
filming you knew what you were doing so
much a film you show up for the first
day and you're meeting the actor for the
first time you're reading the words for
the first time that had very much a
theater approach I think I was a little
spoiled actually as a result
[Music]
showing the jury the reason my client is
fired was because he falsified his
resume not because he went above your
head and reported that trucks were not
getting fixed and people were dying as a
result correct
say yes
yes that was my first time playing a
real person and he had passed away a few
years prior so you have a there's a
unique burden that comes with that we
met his family met his brother and you
know you just you get you get personal
stories and socially relevant topic
which I was excited to be a part of and
a really fun role a director uh the
Kasson Brothers Mark cassen who is now
my producing partner and dear friend it
was a really exciting time very
creatively satisfying role but also a
really demanding one and that kind of
coincided right when I got
the offer to do Captain America you know
and I had been coming off of puncture
and was just so content with
that type of filmmaking and Captain
America just felt like a different
universe and I just was really unsure if
that's the world I wanted to drift into
so that's that's part of the reasons I
kind of was so wary and said no to
Captain America a couple times because
of the experience I had on puncture you
know I just wasn't sure which Avenue to
take in retrospect you realize that
nothing's binary you can kind of
construct any sort of path you'd like
but at the time it just felt
overwhelming yeah well at least I have
the courage to lose for what's right
sometimes on big big movies there's a
hundred Cooks in the kitchen every
decision is filtered through you know a
billion teams of people and working on
puncture just feels like a couple people
with a camera you have a much more
intimate Hands-On approach to these
aspects and it just feels maybe a little
more protected I mean I've been a part
of films where you do your job and then
it there's so many steps that's the
nature of filmmaking I mean you see the
final product you say wow that is not
what I thought this was going to be such
as the case with big big movies smaller
movies it almost feels like you can
guide them along a bit more because
there's just less people involved
pain hustlers
I play Pete Brenner he's a drug rep he's
representative of a mentality that's
pretty ubiquitous in the field which is
just like hey I'm just doing my job just
doing my job it's not my fault I'm not
the one writing the prescriptions I'm
not the one killing people I'm just
passing it from A to B so it's kind of
uh this Twisted perspective that
absolves anyone from responsibility of
this epidemic What specifically drew me
was Emily you know her and I are
friendly and and we've been looking for
something to do together pretty keen on
joining regardless but the story ended
up being very timely and important
anytime you can
work with a certain caliber of people on
a project that's relevant and important
and moves the needle in Social ways you
jump on board I think there's different
motivating factors creative appetites
Drift from one thing to the next one
time you might just want something
that's a comedy something that's you
know fun or you know or a horror
suspense but sometimes you know you
might even
stumble across an issue that means
something to you personally and then
actively go pursue a project that
reflects that issue it's a blessing and
and I'm
uh very creatively satisfied and you
know personally satisfied that I that I
get to do that from time to time